today's video has been made possible by
wandrium stick around until the end to
find out more with God of War Ragnarok
only a few days away now seems like a
good time for a speedy recap of the
story in the Norse world so far the
Story begins with a much older looking
Kratos in a place that we now know is
the Norse World Kratos moving on has a
new family a son atreus and well he had
a wife but unfortunately the opening
sequence consists of you performing
funeral rights as she has died the main
premise is for Kratos and atreus to
scatter her ashes atop the tallest
mountain however this is a god of war
and we know it was never going to be
that simple after some father-son
bonding and a deceivingly slow start to
the game we get thrown straight into the
chaos when a mysterious stranger comes
knocking looking for answers but mostly
just trouble this heavily tatted
stranger posing as Conor McGregor is The
God baldir Who clearly knows of Kratos
when his questions go unanswered the
encounter turns hostile fairly quickly
after an insane fight Kratos snaps
baldia's neck but he did just spend the
entire boss fight telling us that he
can't feel anything nor can he die so to
no one's surprise that's not the last
time we'll be seeing Boulder Kratos then
meets one half of the Dwarven
blacksmithing Brothers Brock who along
with sindri created his ax and were also
friends of his deceased wife after some
target practice gone wrong Kratos and
atreus meet the witch in the woods
otherwise known as the goddess freyja
the wife of Odin and the overprotective
mother of boldir back in her home she
makes it known that she knows Kratos is
a god from an outside realm and the the
gods of this realm are not too pleased
with his presence we also find out that
atreus is unaware of who his father
truly is or at least his past and divine
nature after throwing his ax in the
ocean Kratos awakens the world serpent
yormingander luckily he's friendly the
world serpent emerging caused the sea
levels to lower and reveal a temple of
tear that was previously submersed here
we meet Brock again and shortly after
his brother sindri who reveals kratos's
wife was called a fey the passage to the
mountain is blocked by a black mist that
can only be dispelled by the light of
alfheim and so to continue on to the
mountain Kratos and atreus must travel
to alfheim the nine Norse worlds all
exist in the same place at the same time
each world has a tower that can be
accessed from tears Temple with the
bifrost bridge using a rune specific to
that realm in alfheim we see the
remnants of a war between the light and
dark elves a few thousand dark elf kills
later the light is retrieved and the
black mist from earlier is dispelled we
end up on a Mountaintop where we once
again see Boulder this time accompanied
by the sons of Thor Modi and magni they
inquire about Kratos and where they can
find him however the man being
questioned seems more interested in
insulting them than helping when they
leave Kratos decides to have a
conversation with the one-eyed man who
is entangled in a tree this man is mimir
the smartest man alive who informs crate
or senatraeus the highest peak in all
the Realms is not in midgard rather
jotenheim mimir offers to help find the
Rune that would unlock the bridge to
yotenheim however he is bound to the the
tree and no weapon can free him so
Kratos has to cut off his head the plan
is to have the witch in the woods
reanimate his head and despite the risk
mimir is more than happy to be free of
Odin's torture either way back in
freya's home she is able to reanimate
mimir using what she refers to as old
magic we now have our new companion
mimir the talking head who in my opinion
is the best addition to the franchise
while searching for a magical chisel
capable of carving the yotun roon needed
to open the bridge Kratos and atreus
finally encounter Modi and magni
needless to say this doesn't end well
for the sons of Thor magni is killed and
Modi runs away it's not long before Modi
returns believing that killing Kratos
will avenge his brother and earn his
father's respect this is also the first
time we see atreus demonstrate the same
spot art and rage as Kratos however he
cannot control it Modi fails once again
and for the second time runs away atreus
who is overcome with sickness is taken
to freyja for her to heal him Kratos
must travel to helheim and retrieve the
heart of the keeper who protects the
bridge of the Damned and so Kratos
travels to Hell reunited with his old
blades and some visions of Athena he
finds the keeper and retrieves the Heart
needed before leaving helheim we see a
brief vision of Zeus back with freyja
she uses the heart to heal atreus she
also confesses that she has a son who
resents her and Kratos should tell
atreus the truth before the same happens
to him after leaving freya's home Kratos
does finally tell atreus that he is a
God and by extension atreus is also one
however this doesn't have the desired
effects the power of being a god changes
atreus for the worse and we see kratos's
fears come true the Newfound power
corrupts him which leads to atreus
killing a beaten and disheveled Modi
against his father's wishes or at least
Were Meant to believe that Modi is dead
being stabbed in his neck and kicked off
a ledge you would assume would be enough
to do so however he is a God and unlike
magni we don't see him die so I wouldn't
be surprised if he returns in Ragnarok
with the Chisel and the Rune the bridge
to yotenheim is formed Kratos and atreus
can see the Mountaintop and finally
scatter face ashes except they can't cue
Boulder for another insane boss fight we
then end up back in hell where we learn
more of Boulder's mother issues fearing
her son's death Freya made it so he
could never die however the downside is
he could no longer feel anything pain or
pleasure after escaping hell and travel
through the wild Serpent's belly we end
up back in midgard for our final
encounter with Boulder it begins with
him being stabbed by atreus using
mistletoe the only thing that can break
the spell placed on him by his mother
making him vulnerable again when given
the choice to kill baldir Kratos spares
him the lesson he was trying to teach
atreus with Modi however Kratos has no
choice when Boulder tries to kill his
mother freyja he intervenes and just
like their first encounter he snaps his
neck only this time Boulder does die his
last word being snow a reference to
thimble winter the great winter that
comes before Ragnarok Kratos and atreus
have now made an enemy of freyja Kratos
and atreus can finally climb the top of
the highest peak in yotenheim and
Scatter the ashes as promised however
before they do they uncover a rather
interesting prophecy markings on the
wall that show the entire story so far
kratos's wife was a giant making atreus
half giant himself we also see a carving
that shows what many believe to be
kratos's death or some kind of
transference of energy Kratos and
atreyas Scatter the ashes together in a
very heartwarming end just before the
game ends we get the absolute bombshell
dropped on us that the name the Giants
have for atreus and the name his mother
wanted when he was born is Loki
today's video has been made possible by
wandrium for those who are new wandrium
has joined forces with a Great Courses
plus to create a bigger better and more
immersive educational experience than
before there are thousands of lectures
documentaries courses and videos for
everyone the ever-growing library means
there are always new topics whether
you're looking for a quick how-to or
just some mind-blowing facts you can
learn at the pace that suits you best in
the comfort of your own home on pretty
much any device a one dream series I've
recently watched is the secrets of the
occult now this doesn't just cover close
figures performing strange rituals it
covers figures in mythology modern
Traditions mysterious places magic
Witchcraft and even werewolf zombies and
vampires it can range from discussing
UFOs one episode and then Rasputin in
another without any spoilers it's
definitely a series I recommend watching
if you'd like to try one dream for
yourself you can visit wondrium.com
mythology or you can use my link in the
description to start your free trial
today